Film Courage: Gentlemen, for your new movie
DON’T K*** IT which is out now, did your
distributor have a demand for how many zombies
were in the film?
Was there a zombie count that you had to meet?
Mike Mendez: No.
I would have to phrase it more that they indulged
me on that.
They were kind enough to not get in the way.
That was a prerequisite for wanting to do
it was how many people can we get in a 85-minute
running time.
They were very kind to let me do it.
Dolph Lundgren: Yeah.
I think it was…they wanted no less than
300 wasn’t it?
Mike Mendez: I think so.
Yeah.
Totally.
It’s one of my favorite things when someone
lets me make a movie because I always feel
like I’ll say something like “So then
you toy with the zombie and you lift them
and I’m sort of waiting for someone to stop
me because in my mind I’m like “I can’t
believe they’re letting me do this!”
[Laughs].
And that is always a good feeling that we’re
on to something good.
Film Courage: Any other requests that the
distributor asked?
Certain scenes…I know…without a shirt
on…were there certain things that they [requested]…I
mean in all seriousness, that they wanted
as part of the film?
Dolph Lundgren: No.
They were very nice actually.
They were very easy to work with creatively.
I think one thing about this project is everybody
loved the script.
And Mike did a little polish on it to make
it better.
Just added on the bar scene in the beginning
to make it better.
The distributors were quite good about everything
except it had to be shot in 17 days.
That was the only problem.
So I think you know it was more financial
issues but on the creative issue, there was
really nothing.
Mike Mendez: They were super supportive.
Dolph Lundgren: Yeah, they were very cool.
Mike Mendez: The challenge was budgetary.
Time is always the enemy.
But they were very much on board.
And I was surprised because sometimes you
get producers who want to impose their will.
But they let us make the movie that we wanted
to make which is very rare and I really thank
them for that.
Film Courage: I’m wondering who hired whom.
[Dolph] I know you’re an actor/producer
[on this project] and Mike I know you’re
the director.
And [Dolph] you were in the crowdfunding [Indiegogo
campaign] video.
So who hired whom? Dolph Lundgren: I think
I hired myself first?
I read the script.
I thought it was good.
Got involved with the producers.
Met with Mike.
It all happened concurrently.
As usual with these independent movies, it’s
not a simple shot.
There was a producer who was side railed.
He wasn’t part of it anymore.
Mike Mendez: Right.
He passed away, did you know that?
Dolph Lundgren: Yeah, I heard that.
But it was like I met Mike and I read the
script and I really thought it was great.
I then I tried to support the filmmakers in
their endeavor including raising funds for
it.
Film Courage: It’s clear that there is passion
behind it and that you [both] wanted to be
involved in it, you were in the Indiegogo
video, etc.
But I have to take another sort of turn and
that is to say that in this industry you may
take a job that you don’t want to do, how
is that for either of you?
And please don’t name project that you that
you didn’t want to be a part of.
But ones [projects] that you’ve been a part
of because you feel like you have to keep
the [career] engine going.
Dolph Lundgren: You mean like THE EXPENDABLES?
Film Courage: No, no, no.
I just meant…
Dolph Lundgren: I’m just kidding!
[Laughs] Film Courage: No.
I wasn’t going there.
But everyone has to do certain jobs they don’t
want to do and know that it is part of ‘The
Machine.’
And how is it for the two of you knowing that
it is part of being in this business and staying
relevant?
Dolph Lundgren: Well…I can start then…you
know, look.
It’s all in your inner attitude.
You say you don’t want to do it, well that’s
being kind of simplistic about life because
you can always find something good in any
experience, even a bad experience.
Something you think is bad could be a good
experience.
You don’t even know that until years later,
perhaps.
Or weeks later or days later.
Sometimes the bad things in life where you
are being tried are the things that make you
grow.
I mean I look at it that way.
Say if I need to pay off my divorce, for instance
and I need to do a couple of movies, I always
try to find something good in each of those
roles.
Even if perhaps I was sitting on a pile of
money and didn’t have to take that job,
then maybe I would have waited around for
something better.
But what you think is better, a lot of actors
could sit around and wait for a long time
and nothing happens.
So sometimes you can do something and out
of that energy comes something that you can’t
even imagine, you know?
That’s just how life is.
So I just take any role where I try to make
the best of it and try to enjoy it, that’s
how I look at it.
And this movie wasn’t one of those pictures.
This was something that I wanted to do but
I do stuff sometimes that I’m not 100% sure
about.
But most of the time afterwards I’m glad
I did it.
I always think that.
Because something good always happens.
Film Courage: So even if you’re dreading
when the alarm goes off you can always find
some kind of gift that maybe you can learn?
Dolph Lundgren: I’m not dreading it.
But you may be less excited about it.
Maybe you meet somebody on that set or you
learn something as an actor or there is some
revelation you come to by going through the
hardship…it’s part of life.
It’s part of the experience of this life.
Mike Mendez: And I guess fortunately for me
or unfortunately, I don’t find myself in
that position too often.
Because it’s not like people offer me large
sums of money to do anything [laughs] so I
have to kind of find a project, you know?
Because these are low-budget films and you
kind of want to find the best thing that suits
you.
The best is when something is not particularly
a great script, they are not offering you
a lot of money and there are very few perks,
it’s quite easy to say “No, thank you.
Perhaps another time.”
So you’re kind of just trying to find the
best project that excites you, that you can
find something good about it and try to put
your best foot forward and try to make the
most out of the situation.
So kind of like Dolph is saying, trying to
find the silver lining and if there is a thing,
seriously consider that and try to make the
best thing out of it.
Film Courage: Mike according to your IMDB,
you have 24 credits as an editor, 10 as a
director and only 6 as a writer.
It’s surprising to see that you haven't
spent more time writing scripts.
I’m just curious what the reason is?
Mike Mendez: It’s a long-winded answer.
So why don’t I write scripts?
So when I had my first film in Sundance I
had a lot of writing opportunities.
They all got rejected, you know.
I sort of almost have this reaction that directing
is always rewarded and good.
Writing I always feel rejected.
And I almost always feel like it’s too much
on you if you write and direct.
And so at least…and I don’t know (maybe
this will change one day), I like collaborating
with people.
My role as a director (I feel) kind of also
goes with working with a screenwriter.
The same way I’d work with an actor or a
cinematographer or something like that, it’s
about collaboration.
So I think that part of the key to being a
director is knowing that people can do the
job better than you.
And so I feel that there are a lot of people
that are better writers than me, so why not
collaborate with them?
And I still put my stamp on it and what I
like to do by putting my polish and working
with them without having all the pressure
of like “It’s all on me if people hate
the script or the movie.
It’s all on me!”
So I just found that it works better for me,
working with writers.
Film Courage: Dolph we have a lot of actors
that watch our [Film Courage Youtube] channel
and I know you have a fascinating story of
how you got into acting.
But in terms of today 2017, what would you
recommend to someone who is back home in Sweden
or somewhere in the United States that wants
to come to Los Angeles to be an actor?
What would you say to them?
Dolph Lundgren: Well I would say follow your
dreams, follow your instincts.
What is it Stella Adler said “In order to
be in this business you need the soul of a
rose and the hyde of a rhinoceros.”
So that kind of sums it all up.
You are trying to protect that creative part
of you by dealing with a lot of B.S.
every day.
And sometimes you get to express that which
is the reason you get into this business in
the first place.
So I think people should follow their dreams
and not be afraid of failing and trying again.
I mean great actors…look at Morgan Freeman
for instance.
I ran into him not long ago.
Great guy.
Nobody knew who he was until he was about
50-55 years old.
He’d done all these movies and suddenly
he was in DRIVING MISS DAISY.
So there’s a guy who probably had to deal
with a lot of rejection and failure and now
he’s one of the greatest actors in the country
and the world.
So don’t give up.
That’s the thing - don’t give up!
Film Courage: So if you were going to give
them a pep talk before they came here…because
I think a lot of people come out here with
the idea, especially if they’re told that
they are great looking back home or whatever.
And then you come here [to Los Angeles] and
there are so many great looking people that
it’s like…it’s almost overwhelming because
you felt special, maybe?
Dolph Lundgren: Yeah.
It’s true.
I mean, Los Angeles is the place that everybody
comes to from around the whole world.
And I guess you just have to believe in yourself
and work on your craft.
It basically comes down to your ability to
entertain people on screen, if you’re in
the film business or TV business.
When you get your shot, you’ve got to be
ready to take it and then you’ve got to
really go for it at that point.
Like I said, there is all that time in between
that is tough.
What is it, Michael Caine who said “They
pay me to wait.
Acting I do for free.”
So there you go.
There is a lot of waiting around.
So you just have to stay at it and work out
and stay healthy and focus on your craft and
go for it when you get your shot.
Film Courage: I find that interesting in terms
of being ready when something is presented
(and I’ve heard this before to) that most
people aren’t ready.
They think they are.
Were there ever times for the two of you (maybe
we’ll go back to you Mike first) where you
weren’t sure “Am I actually ready?”
when something came your way and you had to
check yourself and say “This is happening
and ….” Mike Mendez: Well I think that
could be said for every project or every film,
you know?
Everything you hope is a new challenge to
yourself and you’re trying something that
is a little different that it’s never…at
least for me I can never just walk through
a movie or just phone it in because there
is always a new challenge and there is always
a new thing.
I’ve never worked with a legendary action
hero [gesturing to Dolph].
So that was like “Okay, how is this going
to go?”
I had never worked with a giant CGI spider
before!
And so you’re constantly trying to find
new challenges for yourself and you always
question it.
I feel it’s healthy.
Most of my friends are filmmakers and I see
it in them.
A lot of them get a big opportunity and are
nervous, even though they might have had a
lot of success before, they’re nervous.
And what we always kind of say is “That’s
good!”
If you’re not nervous I don’t think you’re
in the right place.
You should be nervous.
You should be questioning if you can do it
and if it’s the right thing because I think
you only progress if you put yourself in that
uncomfortable space.
Sort of like “No, I kind of just like doing
this and I’m just going to do this” I
think you become complacent and I don’t
think you do interesting and exciting work.
So I think it is always important to be kind
of out of your comfort zone.
Dolph Lundgren: And also I want to add that
it’s life that matters, not only what you
do on film or on television, because it’s
your personal growth.
Ultimately that is why we are all here.
I mean you can do great work and then you
get fat and take your own life.
After a few years, take your own life or become
a drug addict.
And you can still do great work but it was
not such a great life, maybe?
For you or for your children or for your family
or your friends.
So you have to kind of stay close to yourself
and your personal growth while you’re trying
to get this other stuff done in the business.
And that balance is quite hard to hit.
You know I work on that every day.
And I think that is one of my strengths (perhaps)
is that I’ve stayed close to who I am and
who I was before I got in here in this crazy
town, you know?
I think that is what people have to remember.
Because that is the big thing that will derail
you: failure or success can screw you up,
you know?
It’s the middle way, like Buddha said.
The middle way.
That’s where you should be most of the time.
That is the healthiest way of existing I think.
The big stuff is great, but it always goes
away and it can lead to a lot of negatives.
And the really lows, too are tough, as well.
So you try to stay in the middle ground.
Film Courage: How was that for you to do your
(2015) Ted Talk because you showed yourself
as being human and for most people around
the world they see you as superhuman?
How was this for you?
Because when people do see you they call out
your name as your [various] character(s) “Oh,
Gunner!”
But you’re actually a human being and you
revealed a lot of human things.
How was that?
Dolph Lundgren: The Ted Talk I did was mostly
about my Dad and my upbringing and the abuse
and things like that and also about trying
to help other people.
If you help yourself, the next step is for
you help other people.
Yeah, it was cool.
It was very emotional and it was difficult
to prepare and it was difficult to get up
on stage and stand still and reveal those
things.
But it felt really good, you know.
And afterwards you really feel like a personal
accomplishment.
For me, it was one of the most important moments
in my career.
I mean movies are great and that’s what
the fans see.
But for me as a person, that was a great moment.
I’m glad you liked it.